so let's find out what millionaires
really are John is one John's in Houston
Texas hey John welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how are you
better than I deserve sir what's your
net worth Oh
as of today 1 million six hundred and
seventy-five thousand very cool and
what's it invested in all of that well
let's see we have 1 million three
hundred fifteen the mutual funds and our
house is worth three hundred fifty
thousand very cool and what are you guys
what have you made a year average
through your working lifetime average
here so your working lifetime average I
would say about 130 okay and how old are
you I'm 59 my wife is 54 okay how much
of this did you inherit zero okay and
what have you done for a living what's
your primary career path that's I'm
sorry at mechanic aircraft mechanic yeah
okay my wife is a schoolteacher okay so
did you you've got a a technical degree
or did you get a four-year degree I did
four years in Air Force and got out and
got my EMT powerplant license and also
private pilot on the side okay all right
and so what was your GPA in school never
went to college
but uh four years in Air Force doesn't
mean four years of college okay
so you but you took your technical work
and did they give you a grade on the
technical work you were doing for the to
becoming oh yeah yeah yeah well it was
in the A's didn't really have a GPA
that's a pass/fail situation Yeah right
okay they're all in the you know 95 so
how do you end up with a million three
hundred thousand in your mutual funds at
59 years old what you do to cause that I
have let me just tell you you know we uh
we came from a family of eight kids dad
owned grocery store very small grocery
stores all the kids worked in there
there's one of these situations where
you know you have a grocery store labels
come off the cans so he brings these
cans home you didn't know if you were
gonna get dog food or or canapes
basically you know in the fruit and
stuff like that so fruits fruit you
bring home peaches or apples or whatever
so it's apple pie that's your peach
cobbler whatever sure and you know of
course all the kids worked in the
grocery store and I can remember in high
school making 75 cents an hour then went
into the Air Force and got out I decided
you know there's got to be a better way
so I started investing this is in the
80s I just started investing in anything
and everything you know people back then
they had music CDs and when person say I
bought a CD I would always ask when were
like thank you buy that and then we're
talking about a Michael Jackson CD or
something like that so I was just a nerd
about investing and what was the biggest
Muslim what do you put most money and
you said mutual funds well that's where
I made most of my money but mistakes
along the way I played with commodities
and futures end up losing forty thousand
dollars on that I lost seventy five
thousand and individual tech stocks and
it wasn't but I still started doing
mutual funds because in the back of my
mind I want to get in something stable
and then in 2000 is when I found you and
that's when I really started
accumulating money we got the house paid
off we pay you when paid off one hundred
seventy six thousand dollars in seven
years two daughters went through college
I started the yep my funds for them back
in 85 and 87 for them what's the most
expensive pair of blue jeans you've ever
bought oh gosh
last time I bought blue jeans it's
probably 10 years ago and probably 20
dollars maybe you're not still wearing
those are you yeah okay good for you me
too I just wanted to tell Sharon that
that really happens other than at our
house okay
how many new cars how many new cars have
you bought before you were a millionaire
we we have only bought one brand-new car
and that's when my first first daughter
was you know born and we just felt like
we needed something stable since then
now everything's been used right now
John your
you're a great American hero
congratulations 1 million six hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars you
hear how you did it
is that all Dave Ramsey investment
advice that everybody on the internet
says it's so awful
yeah I'm bragging I'm happy for John
this is the Dave Ramsey show you guys
would be so rich so fast and be able to
do so much not only for yourselves and
for your family but for others
you